>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ron Elving: Good evening
and welcome to the main event.
The last program of the
evening here in the ballroom.
My name is Ron Elving.
I am an editor correspondent
podcaster at NPR
and also a full-time, thank you,
and also a full-time faculty member
at American University
School of Public Affairs.
And it is my very great
pleasure to be here this evening
with John Aloysius Farrell;
Jack Farrell to his friends,
and he has written his third book.
His first book was called "Clarence
Darrow, Attorney for the Damned."
Now I think you should buy
that book just for the title.
His second book was called "Tip
O'Neal and the Democratic Century,"
and then he turned to
Richard Nixon, "The Life."
>> John Farrell: Because he's
such a popular character.
>> Ron Elving: Because
of that trajectory,
I have to ask what made
you turn to Dick Nixon?
>> John Farrell: I was
drawn to his story.
The original subtitle for the
book was "Mr. Richard Nixon,
An American Tragedy," and I was
struck when I did the research
that people like Henry Kissinger
and Elliot Richardson would write
in their diaries or talk on
the phone with each other
and as Watergate was collapsing
around him, they would say,
"This is really like
classic Greek tragedy."
This is really a Shakespearean scene
of someone who has so many gifts,
and yet this amazing tragic
flaw which ended up bringing him
down in quite a Shakespearean
manner.
He was Iago to this own Othello.
He was always whispering in his
own ear, "You're not good enough.
They hate you.
They're against me," and in
the end, it destroyed him,
and he had that one final
moment of recognition.
Some of you may remember on the last
day that he was in the White House
when he addressed his staff and
family in the East Room and he said,
"Remember others may hate you
but if you hate them then you
destroy yourself," and so,
there's this wonderful moment
of self-recognition when he sees
that that the tragic flaw has
brought him down in just the way
that he feared the most, and yet
in the end that's what got him.
>> Ron Elving: I'm
struck by your comparison
to Iago to his own Othello.
I don't believe that
line is in the book.
I think you had said it on another
occasion and I had looked for it
in the book and I don't
believe I found it.
Is that something you have
thought of since writing the book
and what does it mean to you?
>> John Farrell: No.
Actually when you write a proposal
for a book, you sort of try to come
up with analogies to what this story
is, and when I wrote the proposal
for Double Day, that
was in the proposal.
I didn't use it in the book.
I probably should have because
as I went back and prepared to go
out on the book tour, I
came across that line.
I said, "Hey, this is a pretty
good line," and I've used it.
But if you remember the play,
Othello was this great general
and Iago his lieutenant.
Very jealous of him and
starts whispering in his ear
and Iago puts this paranoia in
Othello, and in the end Othello ends
up killing his beautiful
wife Desdemona
because Iago was so
good at doing that.
So Nixon always had this
susceptibility of telling himself
over and over again,
"I'm not good enough,"
and one of the most heart
[inaudible] examples of this is
when he comes back from China,
and he's accomplished everything
that he wanted to do in his life.
He's become president
against all these odds.
Come from the backwoods
of California
to become president
of the United States.
He wants to be a great man
and he sees this opportunity
in the Cold War to drive
a wedge between Red China
and the Soviet Union, and to bring
China into the family of nations.
And long before he was president,
he wrote about this in an article
in the Foreign Affairs Magazine,
talking about how this
new century was going
to be a century --
an information age.
This is Richard Nixon in 1965.
An information age
dominated by computers
and that the old Communist
monolithic societies would not be
able to compete with the
nimbleness of science that's going
to be needed in the 21st century.
So he sees this happening
as he's president.
He goes to China.
He makes this amazing breakthrough,
and he comes back and he's talking
to Henry Kissinger on one of
these infamous White House tapes,
and Iago starts to whisper.
And he says, "You know Henry,
the American people
are a bunch of sheep.
They watched me on television with
all that handshaking and stuff
in China, and you and I know it
really doesn't mean a thing."
And this is Richard Nixon
not really being cynical
about the American people but
badmouthing himself because he had
such a sense of inferiority.
So that's where I -- I should
have used it in the book.
It is a good line.
>> Ron Elving: And then you
mentioned that foreign affairs piece
from 1965 in which he seemed to have
an enormous amount of sophistication
about Asia, and in the book, you
point out that he had toured Asia
as vice-president as part of
his duties for Dwight Eisenhower
and that he had learned a great
deal and impressed a lot of people.
He seemed to have really
taken that on as a study
through much of the
rest of his life.
But one of the things about the
book that got attention as soon
as it came out was you broke
a bit of news that had to do
with the Asian land war that
everyone knew we shouldn't try
to fight but Richard Nixon found us
fighting when he became president
in Vietnam, of course, and the
news that you broke had to do
with a person named Anna Chennault.
Famous to perhaps our generation
and the generation before us,
but not so well known today who
was sent on a mission by the,
if you will, Nixon White House
in waiting before he
was elected president;
when he was still a private citizen
but the nominee of
the Republican party.
What was that all about?
>> John Farrell: Well,
it's almost 50 years.
It'll be 50 years next year.
And Nixon was running in 1968.
An amazing year of turbulence.
The year that Bob Kennedy and Martin
Luther King were assassinated,
and you had Eugene McCarthy
challenging LBJ in New Hampshire.
You had riots at the
Democratic convention.
And in the midst of all this,
Richard Nixon builds a pretty
formidable lead by September of 1968
over his Democratic
opponent Hubert Humphrey
because Lindon Johnson the
sitting president has announced
that he's not going to run for
reelection because of Vietnam.
And then all of a sudden, the
Democratic party starts --
the Democratic voters start
coming home in the fall of 1968.
And the blue collar union
workers, they leave George Wallace
who was running as a
third party candidate
and they start going back
to the Democratic party.
The Eugene McCarthy anti-war
folks start forgiving Humphrey
because he does a little bit
of a tiptoe towards a
split with LBJ on Vietnam.
And all of a sudden what --
at the beginning of September,
Richard Nixon had this young
guy who was a vote counter,
and his name was Allen Greenspan.
>> Ron Elving: Good counter.
>> John Farrell: Yes.
And Allen Greenspan
sends in a memo and says,
"We're going to win
410 electoral votes.
Humphrey will be lucky
if he wins a single state
because Wallace will take the rest."
But it has closed dramatically
by the middle of September,
and then Lindon Johnson
calls Nixon in and says,
"We're seeing some
progress on Vietnam.
I may institute a bombing halt."
Now Richard Nixon thought that
he had lost the 1960 election
because the Kennedy's stole it
from him, and he had seen Johnson
in 1966 do an October surprise in
the off-year congressional elections
by announcing that he was
closer to peace in Vietnam.
So Nixon's paranoia kicks in,
and he sees these forces lined
up against him ready to steal
something from him once again,
and he uses this connection,
a woman named Anna Chennault
who was very well-known
in the palaces of Asia
because her husband Claire
Chennault had led the Flying Tigers
into battle against the Japanese
in World War Two, and he sends her
to the South Vietnamese to tell
them that if they can just hold
on a little bit longer,
Nixon will be elected
and you'll get a better deal.
And so, rather than go to Paris
and join in the peace talks,
which Nixon thinks is a charade,
the South Vietnamese resist.
They don't join in the peace talks.
Now this was pretty much a known
story because at some point
that fall, Lyndon Johnson got
wind of it, and he sent the FBI
out to tail and to tap the --
>> Ron Elving: The tapes.
They always come back.
>> John Farrell: -- to tail
and to tap the Republican,
Claire Chennault, the
Republican envoy;
Anna Chennault the Republican envoy
and the South Vietnamese Embassy
and the presidential
palace in Saigon.
So Johnson is getting
all this information
and he sees what's happening.
He gets on the phone call
with Republican Senators
like Everett Dirkson, and he sees,
"I'm reading their hand Everett,"
and this is darn near treason.
So he confronts Nixon
and Nixon denies it,
but it has actually happened and
the great tragedy of this story is
that there really was a peace feeler
from the Soviet Union
to Johnson that summer.
And the Soviets said, "If you'll
do a bombing halt, we can promise
that there will be productive talks.
We'll get the North
Vietnamese to the table."
So what Nixon saw as a dirty trick,
Johnson actually believed was a
chance to end the war earlier,
but Nixon intercedes and the
South Vietnamese pull back
and the peace talks don't happen,
and Nixon is elected in one
of the closest elections
in American history.
>> Ron Elving: Forty-three
percent of the vote I believe.
>> John Farrell: With
only 43% of the vote.
So elements of this story
come out over the years,
but Nixon always denied
it and if you go back
and watch the famous
Frost/Nixon interviews,
David Frost asks him specifically,
"Did you send Anna Chennault to talk
to the South Vietnamese,"
and Nixon says, "No.
I would never do something
like that."
So the last big piece of
the puzzle and the piece
that confronted Lyndon Johnson
in 1968 was whether Richard
Nixon had been directly involved,
and as I'm going through
this vast amount
of material that's been
released in the last 20 years
at the Nixon Library in Yorba
Linda, there are handwritten notes
by Nixon's chief of staff.
A man named H. R. Bob
Holman, and he's writing
down what Nixon is telling
him and Nixon is saying,
"Keep Anna Chennault working
on the South Vietnamese.
Anyway we can monkey wrench
Johnson's initiative."
And monkey wrench of course
meant throw a monkey wrench
into the gears and stop it.
So that was my little
contribution to history.
History sometimes is like
a rainy day like today,
you're down at the beach and
you pull out a jigsaw puzzle
because there's nothing else to do
and you start putting the
puzzle pieces together.
And then the sun comes
out and you go away
but your brother-in-law
comes up behind you
and he starts putting a few
pieces of the puzzle together
and eventually the
puzzle gets assembled.
So that was my little
piece of the puzzle.
I was glad to contribute to history.
>> Ron Elving: And a
crucial piece it is.
One of the things that
strikes me about your book,
and I think has struck others
as well and reviewers as well,
has been the extraordinary way that
you manage to remain dispassionate
and yet have a sort of edge on the
seat involvement in what's going on.
Now you did not live all
of this history but --
>> John Farrell: Sadly
I lived some of it.
>> Ron Elving: Many of
us have lived much of it.
And I think, for a large
generation, I read the book feeling
as though I was reliving my life.
Did you feel that way at all when
you were going back through this?
Did you feel personally
involved in these events?
The larger events if
not the specific events
of Richard Nixon's life?
>> John Farrell: I was
a little born torn.
I was in college during Watergate.
So I wasn't in college at the time
of the great Vietnam protests,
and yet, Nixon was a bad guy
for people of my generation.
So when I started to go into
his life, I approached it
as a biographer which is
telling myself, "All right.
You have to be objective.
You have to be fair.
You have to look at this guy
dispassionately and see it
from his point of view,"
and what I found as I looked
into Nixon's life was
that my sympathy,
my empathy for him grew even
as I was finding out things
about Watergate or
this about Vietnam,
which I thought was a
horribly, horribly cynical act.
I was looking at where he
came from and what he had
to do to get to where he was.
He was born in the
California outback as I said,
and his father was a blowhard.
Somewhat abusive.
He managed to be someone who could
fail to grow lemons in Orange County
which is one of the most bountiful
citrus belts in the world,
and he took it out on his sons.
And he had five sons and two of
them died in Nixon's childhood.
His baby brother Arthur died in
like a week shocking the family
of meningitis, and then
his older brother Harold
who was the golden boy of the family
contracted tuberculosis and died
over a period of six years that
wasted the family's finances.
So by this point, they had sold
the lemon farm and they had moved
to a crossroads outside of Whittier,
and his father bought an
abandoned church and had it toted
down the road and put on this
corner, and opened a grocery store
and began to sell groceries
out of this abandoned church.
And Dick's job was to drive into
Los Angeles to the markets at 3 a.m.
and get the produce and bring it
back to the store and polish it
and prepare it and
then go off to school.
And he did this while
trying to maintain a lot
of extracurricular activities;
drama, football, debate,
and it was very successful,
very bright individual.
But all the time knowing that
the good kids inside Whittier,
the kids in the garden side of
this town looked down on him
because of his family situation.
So he was always had
this resentment,
but at the same time this
amazing drive and resilience.
If there's anything to admire about
Dick Nixon it's the resilience.
The ability to pick himself up and
even in the last years of his life
after Watergate to mount
a semi successful comeback
at least public relations wise
until he appears on the cover
of Newsweek Magazine
with a big headline,
"He's back," and Nixon [inaudible].
>> Ron Elving: And Nixon won as
you said in 1968, 43% or not,
he won the electoral college
because it was a three-way vote
with George Wallace
and Hubert Humphrey.
So then he is president and he
does continue the Vietnam War
but we get changes in
the way draft works,
and we start to [inaudible] the war
more aggressively and people kind
of step back a little back.
College campuses get
a little bit cooler.
Not so much after the
Cambodian invasion in 1970
but you know what I'm talking about.
In general he deescalated and moved
us towards an American withdrawal
which eventually would happen, but
he also did a lot of other things.
Especially in that first term
which stand to surprise people
who don't remember those years.
I'm going to refer to a few of them.
He expanded Social
Security benefits.
The EPA Act that he
signed, OSHA, the Safety
and Occupational Health
Administration.
Title 9 for women athletes.
He had a healthcare proposal
you write about in the book
that was amazingly like what
we now think of as Obamacare.
>> John Ferrell: Very close
to what we see as Obamacare.
His administration pioneered
the idea that we should --
rather than go to a single payer
system, rather than Medicare
for all, rather than a Canadian
or a European type system,
that we should just tell the
insurance companies that --
tell the American companies that
everybody's got to have insurance.
We're going to keep the
private insurance framework
and very slight differences
between that principle and Obama's
in that Nixon's principle
was to have every --
make it a mandate for every
employer to provide insurance;
whereas Obama's mandate was that
all of us have to buy insurance
if our employers isn't doing it.
And Ted Kennedy told
me before he died,
he said this was my biggest
legislative error was not taking
this deal from Nixon.
Especially Nixon offered it twice in
each of his two terms and especially
in 1973 when he was desperate for
domestic support and offered it,
but the Democrats looked at him
and said, "You know, he's so weak.
We're going to get him out.
A new president will come in,
and with the new president
we'll get Medicare for all.
We'll get single payor,"
and it turned
out to be Jimmy Carter a
conservative from Georgia,
and the economy inflation was raging
and Carter had promised a
balanced budget; and so,
instead of getting
national healthcare,
you had a huge fight break
out between Ted Kennedy
and Jimmy Carter.
He challenges Jimmy Carter
in the primaries in 1980,
and Ronald Reagan is elected,
and Harold's in this
new conservative era.
So Ted Kennedy knew he had
missed his chance in 1973
by not taking Richard
Nixon's proposal.
>> Ron Elving: When
he had an opportunity.
But there were all these other
things that Nixon managed
to accomplish that
would by today's lights,
certainly in the post-Reagan
era or in our current era,
would count as liberal programs.
Expansions of government
power, provision of new rights,
provision of new programs
and benefits for people.
Did he get any kind of satisfaction
from that part of his legacy?
Did he have any joy in it?
>> John Ferrell: Two things.
One is that he had been part
of the World War 2 generation,
and the World War 2 generation
had seen a great crisis;
two great crises.
The Depression and then World War 2
and had seen how muscular
government could fix problems.
So it was not like in
the post-Reagan era
where Bill Clinton says the
era of big government is over,
or Reagan said, "Government
is not the solution.
Government is the problem."
To Nixon and to Dwight Eisenhower,
in particular who Nixon served
as vice-president, there
was nothing to be ashamed of
or afraid about government.
If we need it for national
defense to build highways
across the country connecting every
state capital, we would just do it.
That was the way that
Dwight Eisenhower thought
because when he had to
invade Normandy and bring
down Adolph Hitler it was
do we need 5000 ships?
Well, let's get 10,000 ships.
This was their thinking.
So there was really no feeling that
government was this great evil force
in our lives in those days;
the World War 2 generation
felt differently.
Nixon himself had certain things in
the domestic side that he realized
that he needed to do for the public.
The environment is a prime example.
He's elected and three days later
we have the biggest oil spill
in our history up to that time
in Santa Barbara, California,
and Nixon flies out
there and this is just
as the environmental
movement is kicking off
and Nixon has two choices.
He can either go along
with it or he can resist it
and he sees it's vastly popular.
He has sort of a gut feeling that
California is a beautiful place
and we should keep it that way;
and so, you get this amazing tide
of environmental measures.
And it's in the book that at one
point the major environmental
organizations were polled
and they were asked,
"Who was the best green president,"
and Teddy Roosevelt came in first
and Richard Millhouse
Nixon came in second.
So it's really a formidable record.
But then there's other
things that happened too.
He was -- I once said that the
subtitle to the book should be
and yet, because as you
read the book you'll see
that Nixon was the one who brought
about the deliberate polarization
of America on racial matters.
The so-called southern strategy, and
yet, in the Nixon Administration,
there was more desegregation
of southern schools
than in the Johnson
Administration, Eisenhower,
and Kennedy Administration.
His administration very quietly,
prodded by the Supreme Court,
but very quietly, desegregated
the southern schools to the point
that polls of southern black voters
in the 1970s gave Nixon
a 53 to 47 polarity.
It was really appreciated but Nixon
didn't want the rest of the country
to know about it because
he had been so successful
with the southern strategy.
So at the same time that
he's quietly doing that,
he's appointing people
like Clement Haynsworth
and Howard Carlswell
to the Supreme Court.
Guys that were really
borderline if not outright racist,
and then when they were defeated
by Congress making these impassioned
stands that he was the only one
who understood the south.
So while he was doing the
right thing quietly not wanting
to let the south know
that he was doing it,
he would take these
outrageous steps to make it look
like he was against bussing.
He knew that there was
this feeling of resentment
that people had in the late 1960s.
That white middle voters, the people
that he called his great silent
majority and that he could tap it
by telling them that, "Well,
these minorities want it easy.
They want to leap ahead
of you in line.
They don't want to do the hard
work that you did," and he played
that very successfully and
really introduced that strain
into American political life
and it's still with us today.
>> Ron Elving: You know, the morbid
fascination that Richard Nixon had
with the media and that to some
degree comes to fruition with some
of the things that he did in
the Watergate larger conspiracy.
You don't really start writing about
Watergate or focusing on Watergate
or using that term until the book
is into the page numbers of 400s,
and maybe some people would
be disappointed in that.
But in another sense,
you're actually explaining Watergate
almost from the very beginning.
You're talking about what it was
in Richard Nixon that led him
to his relationship with the media
and then ultimately to Watergate.
Talk a little bit about
his early relationships
with the media in Orange County.
Some of the little
newspapers and then
of course the Los Angeles
Times of the 1940s and 50s.
>> John Farrell: Yes.
There's a great irony that both
Donald Trump and Richard Nixon are
so anti-press because both of them
were really creations of the press.
In Nixon's case, in
Southern California,
the Los Angeles Times was like
the great elephant in the room.
A really hard-lined
conservative newspaper,
and from the beginning
took an interest
in young Dick Nixon's career
and promoted him especially
in the 1950 senate race when he ran
against a congresswoman
named Helen Gahagan Douglas.
>> Ron Elving: The pink lady.
>> John Farrell: The pink lady.
>> Ron Elving: Although
he did not name her that.
He did not call her that.
>> John Farrell: No.
She was actually first of the line
by her democratic opponents
in the primaries.
And that's the kind of stuff
that I was talking about.
When you think about Nixon
going in as a writer,
you think about the 1950 race and
you say, "Ah, horrible demagoguery.
He was the one who
called her the pink lady."
Well, it was horrible demagoguery.
By the last days of the election,
he was literally accusing her
of being treasonous and embracing
Red China which had just come
across the border and
joined the Korean War.
>> Ron Elving: Because the
Korean War had started during
that campaign.
>> John Farrell: It started
during that campaign.
But, where were we?
Where was I?
>> Ron Elving: Well, we were talking
about his relationship
with the LA Times.
>> John Farrell: Oh, yes.
The Los Angeles Times.
And same thing with Donald Trump.
I mean I grew up on Long Island.
I spent a lot of time as a political
reporter reading the Daily News,
reading the New York Post
and seeing Donald Trump grow
by manipulating the tabloid
atmosphere in New York City,
and then, of course, during the
campaign he was such a feature
on the evening cable news that it
is a great irony that both Nixon
and Trump both identify
the press as the enemy
or the enemy of the people.
>> Ron Elving: Now that's parallel
that I had hoped you
might be able to make.
It carries on when they get
to Washington, doesn't it?
Because when Richard Nixon came
east first as a congressman,
then a senator and vice-president,
he discovered a very
different attitude
in the media towards his career.
>> John Farrell: Yes, definitely.
But he took down a
series of liberal icons.
It is unavoidable that
strong elements
of the eastern press were liberal.
In Nixon's case in the 1950s,
many of them were liberal
Republican but still liberal.
When he went after Earl Warren and
he took down Alger Hiss, the spy
and Harry Truman's state department.
>> Ron Elving: Jerry Voorhis.
>> John Farrell: He defeated Jerry
Voorhis and his first campaign,
and Helen Gahagan Douglas.
He was putting skins up on the
wall that really marked him
as a young conservative aggressive
comer when he got to Washington
and the press indeed did several --
some elements of the press
did really a job on him.
Drew Pearson.
The great [inaudible]
picked him as a target.
Herblock the cartoonist for the
Washington Post in particular,
would do these cartoons to the point
that Nixon couldn't stand his
daughters to read the morning paper,
and so, he cancelled his
morning Washington Post
and got it at the office.
So, there was an element definitely
that took that native paranoia
within his spirit and
accentuated it in Washington.
But it was there from the beginning
because that first campaign,
another little piece of the
jigsaw puzzle that I found was
that Nixon loved to make lists.
He would sit in an armchair, put
his feet up with a yellow legal pad,
all the way even through his
presidency, and just write out lists
and thoughts on yellow legal pads.
And one of these I found, one of
the first ones when he came back
from the war, and he was running
for Congress, a complete unknown,
and there one of the
things to do is like, okay,
go to the rotary meetings, stop by
the local newspaper and buy an ad,
set up a voter organization in
such and such a neighborhood.
Put spies in the Voorhis camp.
This is [inaudible].
There was something there from the
very beginning that eventually grew
and flourished and erupted
in Watergate, but all along,
he definitely had opposition from
the liberal press that egged him on.
>> Ron Elving: And he always
believed, perhaps because of
that early experience that he
had with individual publishers,
editorialists, reporters, that every
newspaper decided whether they were
with you or against
you and that was it.
Not just on the editorial page.
Not just in terms of endorsement,
but in terms of how they
covered you in the news.
>> John Farrell: And then he had
some horrible misfortune in 1960.
He runs against the most charismatic
candidate of the time, Jack Kennedy,
who loved the press, who was
a reporter, who could relate
with the press, and there is
absolutely no doubt in history
that the 1960 press core, the actual
reporters were sided with Kennedy.
Nixon got more editorial
endorsements and Nixon was,
who had used television
so masterfully
in the famous Checker's
speech was betrayed
by his performance in the debates.
So there were balancing
factors in the media
but definitely the campaign
reporters that he dealt
with every day were very much pro
Kennedy and there's really no doubt
in history that this reinforced
his idea that reporters were
at least ideologically on the tape.
>> Ron Elving: And I want to
give you all an opportunity
to ask questions so I'll just ask
you one more as people come forward
and you can line up here at
the microphone so we have one
on either side if you'd
like to ask question.
But let me just ask you, the
name of Donald Trump has come up,
and it's difficult to not draw
parallels between these characters.
Other people have done some between
the character of Richard Nixon
and the character of Donald Trump.
The media element is an obvious one.
What else do you draw as a
biography and as a reporter,
what else do you draw as
lessons from this period
when we come to our own era?
>> John Farrell: I don't
think there's a lot
of comparison between the two men.
Nixon was definitely a
foreign policy intellectual.
He read and wrote books.
Because he had served as
Eisenhower's vice-president,
he had a great dignity and respect
for the office that didn't blind him
to commit the sins of Watergate,
but still he would
never treat it vulgarly.
So in that regard, there's
really not a lot of comparison
between the -- I don't see a lot
of comparison between the two men.
They both campaigned and perhaps
Trump took this from Nixon,
with sort of this politics
of grievance and resentment.
And in fact, at times, Trump,
when he was campaigning,
he even used the phrases
that Nixon used.
You know, "It's going to be a law
and order administration,"
and things like that.
And the sins that Nixon was charged
with or that had been alleged
about our President
Trump are very similar.
The Saturday night massacre in which
Nixon fired the special prosecutor
is compared very closely
to Nixon firing the --
Trump firing the FBI director
who was leading the investigation
into Nixon, and there's
all this talk
that perhaps Trump will fire
today's special prosecutor.
So it's more of a superficial
resemblance I think
than an actual one.
>> Ron Elving: Thank you.
And we will take your
questions, sir.
This gentleman on the left.
>> Thank you very much.
This concerns the five
Watergate burglars.
I had the pleasure this week
of attending a continuing legal
education program presented
by John Dean, and he
said very definitively
without any hesitation whatsoever,
that if the five burglars had
not been apprehended breaking
into the democratic
headquarters at the Watergate,
they had another place to go that
very evening, and that other place
to go was McGovern
headquarters because people
in the White House had expressed an
interest in knowing what was going
on there, and the point that
he made is that while the break
in at the DMC did not emanate
from the White House per se,
the cover up did but
not the DNC break in.
The subsequent break in that
never got a chance to happen
at McGovern headquarters did
emanate from certain individuals
in the White House and
therefore ironically
if the five guys had managed to
make it to destination number two,
then the Watergate house of cards
might have come down sooner.
I'd very much appreciate
your addressing that.
>> John Farrell: There are no
questions anymore about Watergate.
The tapes show Nixon talking
to Bob Holden saying, "Bob,
we need more wiretapping.
You need to go out now and follow
the Democratic candidates."
And in this vast flood of paper
that's been released in the last 30
or 40 years, you have evidence
that it wasn't just
McGovern headquarters.
That they also -- Muskie
was the frontrunner.
They had opened up an office next
to Muskie headquarters to serve
as a listening post
and had gotten --
by putting spies in the Muskie
camp had gotten floor plans
of Muskie showing where the
different desks and telephones were.
So this was almost everyone of
Nixon's aides at the White House
with the exception of Henry
Kissinger had some sort
of involvement in one
of these dirty tricks.
It was a massive campaign.
And indeed, as you say, it's a
signal of what clowns Gordon Liddy
and Howard Hunt were that they
thought that they could break
into the Democratic National
Committee at 11:00 p.m.
and burglar it and install
bugs and take photographs
and then still be fresh
enough and energetic enough
that at 3:00 a.m. they would
drive up to Capitol Hillis
to McGovern headquarters which they
had tried unsuccessfully to break
into three times already and break
successfully do it the same night.
And they were doing it because Liddy
and Hunt had loaned all this money
that they had been given and their
bosses called them in and Mitchell
and others were saying,
"Where's the fruits
of what we're spending money
on," and so they panicked,
and they did incredibly
stupid things throughout
that whole episode.
But Dean is right in that regard.
>> He also said that
the motive for breaking
into the McGovern headquarters
was to see
if the McGovern people had come
across some of the information
about the Elsburg psychiatric
break in, and they wanted to know
if they were going to get hit with
[inaudible] material from them.
>> John Farrell: I wouldn't
argue with him about that.
I know that part of
the motive for the --
I think there were many
motives for what they wanted.
They basically wanted
anything and everything.
You can't just say, well
Watergate just happened because so
and so wanted this
particular piece of paper.
There were lots of things
that they were looking for.
>> Ron Elving: Thank you, and
thank you for your question.
Let's take one from over here.
>> So I guess some of
the strangest moments
from a really strange presidency was
in, I think, 1970 after the bombing
of Cambodia and he has this weird
press conference, and he's staying
up all night calling like 50
different people and he decides
to go to the Lincoln
Memorial and talk face-to-face
with a bunch of student protestors.
And I think it was in the
Oliver Stone film too.
They kind of showed that as well.
I was wondering, what
did you take from that?
What do you think Richard Nixon
was looking for in that encounter?
Why do you think he
went [inaudible]?
>> John Farrell: I think the
key to that encounter happens
after he leaves the Lincoln Memorial
and he goes up to the capital.
And he's up at the capital and
he tries to get into the senate.
He can't, it's locked, but he
goes to the house representatives
and he's brought his valet because
the whole purpose of this jaunt is
to show Manila the glories
of Washington at night.
And so, he has him get up --
Nixon sits in the chairs below
and he has Manila get up on
the dias and give a speech.
And as they're walking out and
leaving, there's a cleaning lady,
and she comes over and
she's carrying her bible.
And she says, "Hi, Mr. President."
I can't remember whether she
asked him to sign the bible
or he just notices it and he says,
"Read your bible and
you'll be a saint.
My mother was a saint," and Nixon's
mother throughout his life was sort
of his conscience, and she
had died only, I think,
two years before he
finally won the presidency.
And throughout that night,
there's references in his ramblings
about his mom and you can make
sort of the psychological argument
that he was very concerned about
the fact that she would not approve
of him expanding the war in the
way that he did into Cambodia.
That the death of the four students
at Kent State would be something
that she would really object to
and that he was expressing not only
tension but also some small bit
of guilt and shame about his mom.
That's at least the way
that I've always interpreted
that remark; my mother was a saint.
You be a saint too.
>> Ron Elving: Let's see if we can
get to a couple more over here.
>> Perhaps it would have been better
if Richard Nixon had
never become president.
But given that he did,
I've always believed
that it would have been better for
Nixon, for the Republican party
and for the country, if he had
won in 1960 rather than 1968.
Is that a sentiment
that you share or not?
>> John Farrell: Nixon was amazing
in that all three times he ran
for president, he ran as the more
moderate candidate in the race.
He was more moderate than JFK.
He was more moderate than George
Wallace and later Hubert Humphrey
and he certainly was more moderate
than George McGovern in 1972.
So he always represented
sort of the stayed center.
And if he had gotten
elected in 1960,
I don't know how he
would have handled Cuba.
It's awful to play those
hands out in retrospect.
I know that he would have
supported the Bay of Pigs invasion.
He always claimed that he
never would have let it go
on in a half assessed
way the way Kennedy did.
It would have been a full
scale invasion the way
that Ike invaded Normandy.
So you still might have
had the missiles of October
but they might have been
the missiles of April 1961.
Instead if this provoked a
super power confrontation.
But he definitely was
a calmer man in 1960.
Not a great candidate.
Lost that race for a reason.
Became really close
and actually believed
that he had actually won it.
>> Ron Elving: Thank you.
Sir?
>> So you had said that one
of Nixon's most admirable
traits was his resilience.
So there were two great
comebacks in his career.
One was after losing the
presidency in 1960 and then
after Watergate of course.
How did he go about
engineering these comebacks
and why did the American
people largely accept them?
>> John Farrell: The first comeback
which Pat Buchanan has written a
book called "The Greatest Comeback"
and I would say that that's true.
Maybe the greatest comeback
in political history.
To come back from 1960 to 68.
In 1968, you can't believe the
chaos that Americans had been in,
and what they wanted was just some
sort of semblance of normalcy.
And you find that all, even the
most passionate liberal detractors
of Richard Nixon, Norman Mailer,
Hunter Thompson, were writing,
Walter [inaudible], were writing
on his behalf in the '68 campaign
and saying here is a seasoned
steady hand that may be able
to get us out of Vietnam.
So I think that his ability to
present himself as a moderate,
as an experienced man
was what worked in 1960.
I think the second comeback
is not terribly important.
I don't think it will make
much difference in history,
but he really did show some
of himself, for example,
in the Frost/Nixon debates.
If you've seen the movie or
the play, there's a moment
where David Frost very dramatically
takes his clipboard and throws it
on the floor and says,
"You have to lay more
of yourself bare here otherwise
you'll never forgive yourself.
This is your opportunity,"
and he has
that great moment where
he says, "Yeah.
I gave them the sword and they
stuck it in and twisted it,
and I would have done
the same thing myself."
So, he was never a man
to be underestimated.
He had great raw political
skills, and like I said,
that tremendous resilience.
>> Ron Elving: Thank
you for your question.
Sir, we just had time
for a few more.
>> Couple of questions.
The day Richard Nixon
died on April 22nd, '94,
when did you hear the news about it?
>> John Farrell: I don't know.
I can't remember.
Do you remember where you were?
>> I think -- I was
that home evening.
[Inaudible].
>> John Farrell: I was surprised.
I thought he might live on longer.
That's a really a Brian
[inaudible] question.
>> Yes. I was wondering did
you read any of his nine books?
>> John Farrell: I read very closely
his memoir, and I think it's one
of the best presidential memoirs.
It's called "RN."
It's very big and thick.
And if anything, he goes
too much into Watergate.
You would think that he would gloss
over it but he really goes in.
He also wrote another book later
in life called "In the Arena"
which was sort of a secondary memoir
where he got some digs
in at his enemies.
But the one that I
enjoyed the most or the two
that I enjoyed the most were
"Six Crises" which what he wrote
after the 1960 lost and then another
book he wrote about great leaders
that he had met when
he was president.
I think it's just called
"Leaders" if I remember correctly.
So RN, Six Crises, and Leaders would
be the three that I would recommend.
>> Ron Elving: Thank you.
Thank you for your questions.
Six Crises would certainly be
part of that first comeback.
Sir?
>> I'm not sure how much you
discussed Gerald Ford in your book,
but how would you compare
and contrast Gerald Ford
as Richard Nixon's VP at a time
when everyone thought Nixon would
be leaving office versus Mike Pence
as Trump's VP while everyone wonders
how long Trump is going to last.
Was Ford as acquiescence
as Pence has been?
>> John Farrell:
The vice-president's job
is a really tough job,
and I covered the White House.
I was a political reporter for a
time before I became a biography.
And you really have
to feel for them.
I don't think that Ford
was too acquiescence.
In the last six months
before Nixon's resignation,
he was sending signals, and
one of them very famously.
At the time when Nixon was under
fire, he went out and he played golf
with Tipp O'Neal at a golf
tournament in Massachusetts,
and Tipp O'Neal was orchestrating
impeachment in the house,
and allowed the photographers
to take a picture of Ford
with his arm around Tipp.
In the last three or four
weeks, he distanced himself,
did not fall on the
sword with Nixon.
I hesitate to make any comparisons
to Trump and Pence because we're not
at that same moment
of crisis and drama.
>> Ron Elving: I think we may just
be able to take one more question.
Thank you, sir, for your question.
Yes?
>> Yes. What do you think would
have happened in the '68 election
if George Wallace was not
a factor and didn't run?
>> John Farrell: I think that in the
end, the number of blue collar votes
that Wallace took from Humphrey
was less than the number of votes
that he took from Nixon
in the border states.
And so, if he had not
run, that would have meant
that Nixon would have taken those
border states and Humphrey ended
up taking those northern
states anyway.
So I think probably Nixon
would have won no matter what.
His message was not that
different from Wallace's.
>> Ron Elving: And the deep south,
the states that voted for Wallace.
>> John Farrell: The deep south
had gone to [inaudible] in 1964
so the solid democratic staff
had been broken up already.
>> So, the one chance Humphrey might
have had was [inaudible] throw it
into the house of representatives.
>> John Farrell: I mean the
big threat to Humphrey was
that these blue collar
workers in Ohio and Illinois
and Michigan were going
to go for Wallace,
and in the end, they did not.
>> Ron Elving: I hate to cut
off the questions but we do have
to give up the room as they say.
Thank you all.
We want to thank the
National Book Festival,
the Library of Congress, and CSPAN.
Thank you to CSPAN for having us on
tonight, and thank you Jack Farrell.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.
[ Silence ]